ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
show welcome back to coffee Zillah took
the weekend off we've been doing a lot
making a lot of videos I love it just
the channel support has been
unbelievable lately and I'm just having
a blast I hope you guys are too and you
know it's just been a lot of fun so I
hope you've loved seeing all the content
because I sure have loved making it now
real quick before we move on to our main
story today I want to address the London
real elephant in the room real quick
okay because I made a video on Friday
and subsequently over the weekend Brian
Rose I don't know how to say this nicely
he sort of melted down on his followers
and was like pretty aggressively going
after them
that post has now been deleted and now
it's been replaced with a post that's
saying oh I'm gonna be transparent I'm
gonna be transparent with the funds bla
bla bla bla I just wanted to take a few
minutes and talk about the digital
freedom platform and hopefully talk
about some of the questions and some of
the misunderstandings that have been
kind of flying around out there
we are gonna dress all of that and we're
gonna address it methodically carefully
with a journalist over at rebel wisdom
who has also been working on this story
he's an incredible journalist I suggest
you watch his two videos on the subject
but we're gonna do a video tomorrow
recapping the whole situation and
hopefully it's the last video I have to
do in London rail because as much fun as
it has been I'm tired I'm tired of
talking about the - we did reach out to
Brian for comment you know he may decide
to reach back out he may not I did
invite him on the show so we're trying
to do this legit guys I mean we are
taking every available step to give him
the opportunity to defend himself
because right now with the available
facts we have it looks really bad for
Brian Rose and hopefully he'll clarify
some things but for now I have something
else I want to talk about which is flip
or flop schemes now we haven't talked
about real estate seminars and scams
before but my goodness they are massive
okay so the company we're talking about
today is Zurich s-- which you probably
haven't heard of basically they've held
a bunch of real estate seminars for
really famous people like you've heard
of them Robert from shark tank you know
what you're really pissing me off right
now the stars of HGTV's flip or flop our
top story tonight they are the stars
behind what
HGTV's biggest shows the stars that
flip-flop have turned their celebrity
into a pitch for a company that promises
to make you rich they ran real estate
seminars for these people using their
endorsements as basically saying oh yeah
there'll be at the seminar except when
they got there they weren't are you
feeling right now what a sham what you
ended up finding out is what were
advertised as free seminars were upsells
into a $2,000 seminar which was an
upsell into a $41,000 seminar where
supposedly you could get rich quick
right it's always selfies about that get
rich quick but you know what there's no
lose no lose for you because they kept
saying you know we have a money-back
guarantee it does not work out for you
and your family as long as you're making
everybody did you everybody does okay
except they didn't what they had was a
guarantee if you jump through a million
hoops you could maybe get a partial
refund back if you also signed a
non-dispersive an agreement to promise
basically gag order don't say anything
but not only that because the hard
selling went on what if like a lot of
these people you don't have the money
for a forty one thousand dollar course
well her ex had a brilliant idea they'd
have you apply for credit cards right
there at the seminar but not only that
because that's that's a sucker's game
right because we already know a bunch of
gurus who encourage their prospective
buyers to go and put it on credit cards
no no Zurich's they're masters they're
masters of the game and so what they did
instead is when calling these credit
card companies you have a limit right
the spending limit based on your current
income so Zeus would tell the people oh
yeah say your income is what we're
telling you it's gonna be in six months
now right like once you're rich from
flip or flop like we're telling you
you're gonna make $100,000 a year say
your income today is what we're
promising your income is gonna be
tomorrow so that you can get a higher
limit but you're gonna make this year as
a real estate investor okay so a good
rule of thumb there would be about 100
cake more than you did last year
we're not lying we're projecting so many
people complain in fact the FTC had to
get involved they never get involved the
Federal Trade Commission is like a bear
in hibernation like constantly people
are yelling at them hey here's this game
here's this game here's a scam and
they're just sleeping
you know how much noise you have to make
in order to get the bear to wake up and
finally do something a lot of noise and
it turned out enough people complain the
Federal Trade Commission finally did
something and they shut it down but what
was unbelievable to me was how a lot of
these stars tried to distance themselves
from Zurich right because look you just
promoted a gigantic scam you know how do
you really shrug that one off I stand by
our product it's our tools it's our
system it's what Tarek and I do I've
only heard very minimal complaints very
minimal complaints when the Federal
Trade Commission shuts you down there's
a little bit more than very minimal
complaints but it gets better because
eventually a watchdog group at Dallas
News reached out to them and said hey
can you answer some questions but they
couldn't show up instead they send in
the video hey Dave this is Tarek this is
my wife Christina and we're really sorry
we couldn't make it to the event instead
they say they're too busy with charities
to answer any hard-hitting questions
working on building this beautiful house
or deserving the veterans and we just
love giving back to the community and
that's what we do we're
and everybody is happy at the end of the
day and they deserve it you know when
you get involved in a scam you want to
be seen next to a charity you want to
immediately grabbed the nearest poor
starving child you can or the next
homeless guy you can't go hey I'm too
busy helping this guy to answer your
questions about my you know alleged
improprieties and we're really sorry we
couldn't make it to the event but we're
here today with Habitat for Humanity did
you talk to the celebrities and ask them
about their connection and and and did
you get any response well I tried I left
voicemail messages for them a couple of
times on the two stories I've written
but they sent me a youtube video which I
posted in which they're standing in
front of a garage and they're saying
they're rehabilitating a house for a
veteran and they said hi but they won't
talk to me about the substance of
whether they're hurting their reputation
by being tied into something like this
you know it goes to show you that just
because someone's popular on TV just
because they're seen as a you know a
star does not mean that they're not
above chilling some worthless scam these
guys were at the top the top of the food
chain the shark tank Robert got he's top
of the food chain but it's never enough
right it's never enough money they're
making millions of dollars with the show
they still have to pitch some shameless
garbage course and you're left holding
the bag let's get right to that the will
to win is that the distinguishing thing
between the winners and the losers the
person isn't first and the person who's
second is it just their desire whoa
well I don't think there's such thing as
losers conferences canceled conference
was never happening unfortunately there
was the scam so we're just letting
people know I'm not kidding
unfortunately I don't like to classify
people that way you know every time you
lose at something you're one step closer
to winning the next time I'm gonna go to
County so that's why I'm like do you
think they're getting scammed
it feels like one it feels like one what
does the scam feel like I don't know
what that is big note here don't fall
for those misleading house-flipping
seminars that's the new message from
federal officials today and don't forget
to smash like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]
or the car
[Music]